[Música]
luli
una pequeña de siete años
ingreso a mi despacho después de familia
acompañada de su hermanita de 5 y su
hermanito de 3 él rápidamente se puso a
jugar con unos autos y unos camioncitos
que yo tenía allí en el juzgado en el
piso nomás
sus hermanitas se sentaron frente a mí
mirando para abajo
jugando con sus propios pies
la mayor
levanto su vista y antes que yo empezar
a hablar me pregunto vos sos el que nos
va a buscar un papá y una mamá porque
nosotros queremos tener
el papá
y una mamá
bueno si dije puede ser
ese es un silencio
levanto nuevamente su mirada y me dijo
cuánto tiempo falta
bueno un tiempito dije y hay como si
fuera una película de los años 40
empezaron a pasar por mi mirada por mi
mente informes que subían informes que
bajaban
un tiempo d
que se diluía entre papeles y papelitos
ahí nomás ella
sacó su mirada de sus propios dedos y me
dijo cuánto tiempo es un tiempito
este relato se relato de una situación
real que me tocó vivir como juez de
familia en esos diez años que estuve en
familia 5 de rosa díez
otros casos y otros relatos se fueron
acumulando y lo fui
juntando en un pequeño librito
este año decidí ampliar el libro contar
nuevas historias y transformarlo en una
obra de teatro
una obra de teatro escrita por un juez
es la mayor
de las cosas raras que tiene esta obra
sino que la estamos presentando en
rosario ya decimos dos veces ayer en
santa fe y lo vamos a hacer en varios
lados del país
protagonizada por empleados judiciales
son juezas y jueces provinciales un juez
federal una secretaria de cámara una
secretaria civil y comercial un relator
de cámara pro secretarias del fuero de
familia empleadas y empleados judiciales
y un grupo de adolescentes que se están
formando en teatro y en comedias
musicales en la mutual de la asociación
médica de rosario el eje de la obra de
teatro es el tiempo
el tiempo de los niños pero también el
tiempo de otras personas en situación de
vulnerabilidad las mujeres los ancianos
los enfermos mentales
los discapacitados
y otra vez el eje
pasa por el tiempo
muchas veces muchas veces me han
preguntado amigos amigas gente
periodistas
porque las personas que quieren adoptar
tienen que esperar tanto tiempo porque
es tan burocrático el sistema de
adopción porque se le ponen tantas
trabas y tantos obstáculos a la adopción
yo le voy a proponer una hipótesis vamos
a formular una hipótesis
supongamos que todas las madres y todos
los padres de nuestro país están en
condiciones de criar a sus hijos
de nuevo todas las madres y todos los
padres de nuestro país están en
condiciones de criar a sus hijos a ver
con aciertos y con errores pero sin
vulnerar gravemente sus derechos si la
cosa fuera así si la cosa fuera así no
habría opción y por ende quién quiere
ser papá o quiere ser mamá no
encontraría por la adopción el camino
para seguir
ahora bien todos sabemos que no es
cierto está esta hipótesis no no nos
encontramos palpable en la realidad no
la vemos cotidianamente hay una porción
de padres y de madres que no están en
esa condición
así que hacer un paréntesis en general
en esta situación se encuentra una mujer
sola y puede ser que una mujer decida no
ser madre
y decida dar a su hijo en adopción que
sea una otra familia la que lo críe
pero también es cierto que hay un
conjunto de personas padres madres
familias que son graves vulneradoras de
los derechos de sus pibes
graves vulneradoras y es allí en esos
casos en donde el estado tiene que tomar
decisiones de extremas por ende son esta
es la situación en la que brindan un
sustento a la idea de adopción
vamos a hacer un poquito más complejo el
tema
ustedes no conocen a chicos que sean
criados de las chicas que sean criados
con con sus abuelas con sus abuelos con
sus hermanos con sus hermanas con sus
tías con sus tíos se crían en el seno de
esa familia y la verdad en su gran
mayoría no piensan que su abuela es su
madre o que su hermano es su padre o que
su tía y su tía son su mamá no no
ellos son nietos sobrinos hermanos
esto nos dice entonces que la adopción
no es la única salida para la situación
de chicos que tienen
y derechos gravemente vulnerados el
derecho de los adultos a ser padres
adoptivos va a depender
indefectiblemente de la existencia de
chicos y de chicas que tengan la
necesidad de contar con una familia que
los críe como tales
por ende el derecho que está puesto
sobre la mesa en el derecho de los pides
el derecho de las pibas lo que está
puesto en juego son los tiempos de los
niños y de las niñas no los tiempos de
los adultos
hay algunos tiempos por los que nadie
pregunta y por los que nadie hace
grandes cuestionamientos de algunos
tiempos por lo que no vienen a
preguntarte qué pasa con ellos
una niña de escuela primaria se
entrevista con su maestra le cuenta algo
a la maestra le cuenta que existe una
situación de abuso la maestra ya había
visto algunas marcas ya había visto
alguna situación de violencia entonces
siguiendo los pasos que tiene que seguir
habla con la vicedirectora y la
vicedirectora decide hablar con la
directora y la directora decide hablar
con el ministerio de educación
y el tiempo
una fonoaudióloga
está entrevistando una paciente
y ve delante suyo una mirada triste
entonces con la mirada triste de su
paciente decide hablar con la enfermera
y la enfermera las dos juntas van a
hablar con la responsable del centro de
salud y la responsable del centro de
salud con el secretario y otra vez el
tiempo que se va
por ese tiempo
por el que va desde que se toma
conocimiento se toma se constata la
situación de abuso hasta que el estado
toma una decisión por ese tiempo que va
desde qué
el estado tomó esa decisión y logramos
una solución para los pibes y para las
pibas por ese tiempo no pregunta nadie
por ese tiempo no hay grandes reclamos
no hay grandes reclamos por esos tiempos
te preguntan por el tiempo de espera de
algunos
y no por el tiempo de espera de otros
la adopción entonces no es la única
salida a los problemas de los niños con
graves derechos vulnerados
aquella pregunta aquella pregunta que
hizo lula
es una pregunta que tiene una respuesta
en los tiempos de la niñez a ver
le voy a traer otro ejemplo
un ejemplo bien claro
en una oportunidad
ingreso a mi despacho un adolescente un
adolescente de 15 años 15 años
acompañado por una abogada una abogada
del estado una mujer que tenía muchísima
experiencia
ella se sentó a un costado mío
y comenzó a contarme qué pasaba con él
qué bueno había sido sacado por la
dirección de líneas que había vuelto al
barrio que en realidad nunca pudo estar
en su casa que nunca volvió a la escuela
que no podía que hacía mucho tiempo que
estaba en situación de calle
yo balbucea algunas palabras intente
decir un par de cosas y él me paró
en el paro y me dijo
yo sé que usted quiere buscarme una
familia
pero no se preocupe doctor
mi vida está acabada
y cuando el pibe dijo mi vida está
acabada su adolescencia se terminó
la pregunta que me hago es ahí
dónde están nuestros códigos dónde están
nuestras convenciones dónde están
nuestras leyes dónde está nuestro
programa de rehabilitación nuestro
programa de protección nuestros sistemas
de protecciones integrales dónde quedan
todas nuestras hermosas letras
dónde está todo eso dónde están nuestros
relojes
si cuando llegamos a él no es que
llegamos tarde sino que nos llevamos
el tiempo de la niñez tiene plazo de
vencimiento como toda la línea del
tiempo cuando va no vuelve
y ahí está nuevamente la pregunta de
eeuu lee la pregunta del 1 y
preguntándonos y diciéndonos sobre unos
tiempos miren este reloj me lo regalaron
mis compañeros del poder judicial está
muy bueno y está muy bueno para esta
ocasión pero tiene un problema de los
relojes de los tiempos de los adultos no
los tiempos de los niños
ustedes se acuerdan se acuerdan ustedes
cuánto duraban las vacaciones de verano
cuando ustedes estaban en la primaria
recuerdan eran eternas
eran eterna no no terminaron jamás
lo podéis hacer en esos tres meses de
todo recuerdan ustedes cuánto con grande
era cuánto medía el patio de la escuela
volvieron de grande de la escuela
vieron los chiquitos qué es
y el tiempo de los pies se mide con los
relojes de los pies
cuando nosotros queremos encarar la
problemática de la niñez
cuando nosotros intentamos encarar la
problemática de la niña es la única
forma de hacerlo es colocarnos en los
tiempos de nosotros
en la situación del otro
en los derechos de los otros tenemos que
saber que los derechos son los derechos
de los otros y de las otras
y esto que estoy hablando de los niños
no pueden pensar para cualquier
situación de vulnerabilidad piensen en
los tiempos de espera de una mujer
golpeada
porque las golpeadas son las mujeres
las que vienen la violencia familiar son
las mujeres piensa en los tiempos de
espera de los ancianos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
piense en los tiempos de espera de los
ancianos piensa en los tiempos de espera
de los sufrientes mentales
piensen en los tiempos de espera de los
discapacitados
la pregunta de luli
implica una ruptura
un quiebre especialmente para nosotros
un quiebre que nos cuestionen en nuestro
rol los roles que desempeñamos y que
empecemos a pensar esos roles sabiendo
nos que somos potenciales vulneradores
me refiero a los jueces a las juezas a
los secretarias los secretarios los
empleados judiciales los pro secretarios
la gente los funcionarios
administrativos todos ellos tienen que
saber que sus roles son muy importantes
es cierto pero no son más que un
operador más dentro de un sistema
muchísimo más grande
tiene que saber que son operadores de un
sistema y que están tratando con
personas
nosotros tenemos que saber los jueces y
las juezas los secretarios todos los que
mencioné
que cada hoja de ese expediente cada
hoja que se acumula en esos legajos y en
esos expedientes es un tiempito que se
va es un tiempito que se fue y un
tiempito que no vuelve nosotros tenemos
que saber
que si las letras de las leyes que
tenemos adelante nuestro no son
suficientes tenemos que hurgar por otras
y juzgar por otras nuevas
la pregunta del un y cuánto tiempo es un
tiempito también implica un desafío para
la comunidad en general para que la
comunidad se haga cargo también de
acortar esos plazos yo sé que son
decenas centenas miles de maestras
enfermeras forma audióloga psicólogas
vecinos gente que labura en los centros
barriales que han decidido romper la
rigidez de esos esquemas pero
necesitamos muchos más de estas muchas
más y muchos más que que
quieran ir un paso más allá que se sepan
operadores de un sistema mayor pero que
además cuando dan las alarmas y nadie
las escucha se animen a patear las
puertas hay que apropiarse de los
sistemas hay que protegerse de los de
los procesos
tienen que saber nosotros los que somos
los obligados de escuchar esas alarmas
que nuestra función es
habilitar nuestros caminos nuevos
caminos buscar nuevas salidas abrir
nuevas puertas con operadores más del
sistema
de esa forma así entre todas y entre
todos vamos a poder contestar la
pregunta de luli
achicar los sufrimientos
habilitando y haciendo palpable los
derechos
y transformando largos tiempos
en breves tiempos
[Música]